this year's team has been a great team
bro play a little game with you who is
uh most likely show up late to an event
JD Martinez one thousand percent I don't
know I've ever seen him one time he's
barely makes the bus if it's a 130 bus
he's not gonna be there at 129. to sing
the loudest at a karaoke bar I think
Freddie would be so much fun at a
karaoke bar so what about pickup tab at
dinner I think we have a good group for
that I think there's plenty of guys
you'll do it I'll do it for you'll do it
I think we got enough guys that can
actually Jay hey might be the main one
what about losing a fantasy football
league that was me for a long time you
got to find the right Partners I want
three in a row did nothing financial
backer only watch an entire Star Wars
series in one day Tony maybe who will
win a ping pong tournament you did beat
me I would say you though who would be
most like I would say this is probably
me though like be the Dugout DJ or Bic
either one DJ big dickious is pretty
solid that's what I call him I'll give
it to you though you know what you're
doing